nominees for the best performance by an  actor in a supporting role are Eddie  Albert in Roman Holiday paramount  Brandon de Wilda in Shane paramount Jack  Palance in Shane paramount Frank Sinatra  in From Here to Eternity Columbia and  Robert stars in Stalag 17 paramount and  who piece is the winner the winner is  Frank Sinatra  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  um that's clever opening ladies and  gentlemen  I'm deeply thrilled and very moved and I  really really don't know what to say  because this is a whole new kind of  thing you know I song a dance man type  stuff and I'm terribly pleased and if I  start thanking everybody I'll do a one  wheeler up here so I better not and I  just like to say however that they're  doing a lot of songs here tonight how do  you ask me I love you though thank you  very much I'm absolutely true  [Applause]